[Music]
good morning everybody
today uh we have a very interesting talk
uh on hope's pitch and help speech
something we all worry about
by ashik kudavach who
is also a very very interesting person
so ashik is currently
a research scientist at carnegie mellon
university
previously he did both his phd and
postdoc from cmu and because he is from
cmu he
of course knows a lot of you like
sunanna and harsha and vivek also he
mentioned who i don't see in the talk
so so he knows uh quite a bit quite
quite a few people in msr india as well
as
msr in general because he has worked
previously
at msr redmond i think three four years
ago uh with ran and paul
so so it's msi is nothing new to ashik
but but what i really wanted to tell you
all is
uh ashik is a poet he's an established
poet he has
already three published books uh on
collected volumes and poems written in
bangla
and ashik is also a composer he
has composed for the new york theater
uh you can you can imagine like he is
such a multi-dimensional talent so
uh you know we are all looking forward
to listening to your research
and if time permits probably we will
also listen to your poems and songs
so over to you aashiq
thanks uh manojit for this kind
introduction
and thanks a lot for giving me this
wonderful
opportunity to share our research so
it's a joint work
with shifani palu kudeti and jaime
carbonell
so i did my phd and postdoc both from
cmu and i was advised by jaime
in my phd i was working in the
intersection of distributed active
learning and game theory
and in my post talk we moved to
working on in the intersection of low
resource nlp
computational social science and ai for
social good
currently i'm a project scientist at cmu
and uh i'm working with
tom mitchell in the in the same uh area
of
low resource nlp and computational
social science
so um i would like to start with uh
one of my favorite poems by a polish
nobel laureate vislava sims oscar
the title of the poem is the courtesy of
the blind
and the theme of the poem is
the the main protagonist in the poem is
a poet
who visits a blind school
for a reading event and when she
opens the first page of her own book
she notices that in the first poem she
has mentioned
a color and then she
moves to the next page and she notices
that there is a shape
and as she flips keeps flipping on page
after page
she notices that there is a texture and
soon she realizes
that she hasn't written a single poem
that her visually challenged audience
can appreciate in its entirety
the the take-home message from that poem
for me was
the first step towards understanding or
creating an inclusive environment
is to be aware of the disadvantaged
groups existence
and no wonder why terms like
inclusion fairness representation bias
are uh very important terms in
modern ai systems so the first part of
our
this talk we focus on the problem of
including minorities in discussion about
them
and when we say minority it could be
ethnic minority it could be religious
minority
political minority minority along the
gender and health spectrum
and maybe intellectual minority and the
list goes on
but we particularly focus on uh the
rohingyas
they are an ethnic minority in myanmar
and stateless since 1982 so this is the
map of myanmar and the shaded region is
rakhine state
where they usually used to live in the
last 10 years
more than 700 k people were rendered
homeless
and major ethics organizations reported
brutal
state-sponsored violence against them
and myanmar the lh perpetrators denied
any
such ethnic cleansing effort so our work
is not about
the citizenship rights of the rohingyas
or
about myanmar's alleged road rather
we are interested in what we call this
as a 21st century problem a migrant
crisis in the era of
internet where suddenly
a marginalized community is thrust into
global discussion
lot of people are forming very quick
opinion on them
but maybe they have very sparse presence
in
uh sparse online presence to defend
themselves
and this sparse presence can stem from
a language barrier maybe the discussion
is happening in a global language
in which they are not that proficient at
it could be
a lack of internet access or it could be
plain and simple they are too busy
to survive so they don't have time to
check what kind of online hates are
being perpetrated against them
now uh the online world can be very
harsh
if you cannot defend yourself so here
are some of the example comments
that we found in our data set about the
rohingyas
if we look at the phrases like rohingyas
are and
uh draw a word cloud of the token that
follows this phrase
uh we see that a lot of people actually
think that they're illegals they're
terrorists
and if we uh uh present a word cloud
visualization
of the tokens following the phrase send
them to
then most alarmingly we see that hell
is also a suggested place
that online users think they should be
sent to
so the adverse effect of
online hate is uh not only
uh is twofold first
is users exposed to hateful content
targeting a minority
they may find prejudice and the second
thing is
the online hate may not remain always
confined within the online
online world it may trigger offline
violence
causing physical harm so
the research question that we were
interested in is how can
ai help disenfranchised minority
so a typical approach is uh
finding hateful contents and blocking
the negatives so there is a broad
literature
in hate speech detection what we propose
is uh how about amplifying the positives
and we call this help speech aka
voice for the voiceless so we are
primarily interested in
the role of ai in championing or
supporting
a disenfranchised minority when we say
amplifying the positives
we in our paper we do not
specify how to amplify certain continent
content we are more concerned about how
to detect the positives
and amplification is something that is
left for
later research
so help speech is essentially a nuanced
classifier
that automatically detects comments
supporting the rohingyas
uh it could be about like seeking
organizational help
it could be condemning the alleged
oppressor it could be expressing empathy
it could be vocalizing for the right for
the rohingyas
and so on so uh
we focused on uh social media platform
youtube particularly because youtube is
very popular in southeast asia
in fact in india i think it's the number
one social media platform right now in
terms of
its user base and our data set is uh
comments relevant to uh youtube videos
um sorry comments on youtube videos
relevant to the knowing a refugee crisis
so we uh constructed a corpus of 263k
comments
uh from nearly 5000 videos and the
comments are posted by more than 100k
users so our data set is text dataset
uh before i describe some of the
challenges of our project
i want to emphasize a subtle point that
is help speech
is not absence of hate speech so
if a comment is help speech
it definitely implies that it is not
hate speech
but the inverse is not true take this
example comment india is already
overpopulated
we do not have enough resource for the
rohingyas this is definitely not hate
speech
and at the same time it is not helping
the rohingya community
either so help speech and
hate speech those two things
are actually serve two different
purposes to make
the uh life for the
disenfranchised minorities in the online
world safer
in two different ways
now uh i described uh the first few
linguistic challenges that we faced in
this work
uh one is uh the the indian subcontinent
i mean they have huge linguistic
diversity india alone has
22 languages recognized by its
constitution
so one advantage of looking at youtube
comments
is it provides a corpus with topical
focus
but at the same time we have the
challenge of how to extract
a monolingual corpus from a multilingual
data set then the second challenge is
since uh this geographic region
most of the people are speak english as
their second language
there is a broad range of english
proficiency levels
so we saw in in the data set a lot of
grammar and spelling disfluencies
uh phonetic spelling errors for example
it's a bit hurting
that all the developed countries are
selfish
in this comment selfish is most likely
selfish but
the uh true we don't know if hurting is
hurting or heartening and depending on
what it was originally intended to be
the meaning of the comment might
completely the sentiment of the comment
might completely change
so these these are the two linguistic
challenges that we faced in our work
in machine learning challenges uh the
first thing is uh
for any good classy classification
construction we would need an effective
training set
which is balanced which is roughly
having same number of
examples from the two classes in this
case we are dealing with a binary
classification task
and the data set has to be diverse
enough so that
when we train the classifier and if we
run it on in the wild
in the wild performance is good
now positives are rare in this case
because
the vast majority of the comments are
against the rohingya community and if we
randomly
sample uh comments we found that roughly
10 percent of these are voice for the
voiceless or help speech
and we need to find enough positives for
better balance and also
since voice scenes help speech has a
nuanced definition
then the sample should span all positive
and negative subclasses
so in short it becomes like a circular
problem
we need to find positives to construct a
classifier
to discover more positives
a little bit of background on word
meanings before we describe how we
tackle our linguistic challenges uh word
meanings is basically a continuous
representation of words in high
dimensional space
and words with similar meaning are
typically placed near to each other in
the resulting embedding
and the polyglot skip gram over the
meetings
they are skip gram embeddings trained on
a single multilingual corpus
so now i will describe a very useful
result that we found in
one of our works is polyglot enviedings
are very useful for identifying
languages
so if we train a polyglot skipgram
embedding
on a multi-lingual corpus and then
obtain word embeddings
and then for each document
we just average the normalized word
embedding to create a document embedding
once we cluster them we find that the
cluster shows
very clear crisp monolingual separation
for example in the right side we have
21 european languages from the european
europa dataset
and we see that once we clustered them
we see very precise
21 clusters and in the
left side we have uh youtube comments
from orea tv that's a regional
youtube news network in india and there
we see that
the boundaries are not that clearly
separated
but we can still obtain very good
linguistic separation
now one advantage of this technique is
the clustering is largely unsupervised
like once the clustering is done
for each cluster we have to label
its language by just randomly sampling
say 10 comments per cluster
so it's extremely annotation efficient
to figure out the language level of each
of the individual clusters
and once we have language label for the
cluster
whenever we have a new document all that
we have to find out
that what is the nearest uh what is uh
what is uh the cluster it belongs to and
then whatever is the language level
for the cluster we just assign the
language label to the document
so it's a very annotation efficient uh
method and extremely simple
but very powerful because some of the
languages that
we deal in india they don't have
very good support in commercial
solutions
so we can actually use this technique to
obtain uh language labels for those kind
of languages
uh rowing uh corpus apart from english
we identified burmese german
bengali
french arabic hindi malay in our
non-english corpus
and we for the rest of our analysis
we focus on the english corpus that we
extracted
using our polyglot embedding based
language identifier tool
so now we come to our second challenge
how to find positives
so we used multiple active learning
strategies
to boost the number of positives and
construct a balance set
we also used a novel active sampling
technique
to find a diverse set of positives
and i'll describe them one by one
so a time for a little background so
active learning is a well-known
technique to efficiently accumulate
label data
the key philosophy is all data points
are not equally useful
so if we involve the learner to acquire
which data points we need
labels for then the process can be
expedited and it can
be more efficient because the learner is
selecting that
these are the data points that i'm not
very sure of or these are the data
points that i
i'm encountering more often so since the
learner is involved in the whole process
that's why we call it active learning
there are known sampling strategies uh
the most standard strategy is
uncertainty sampling
and then there are some other strategies
like density-based sampling
one-sided extreme or certainty sampling
and so on
a typical active pipeline and learning
pipeline looks like this we start with a
seed set of example
we train a model we use the model to
request labels from unlabeled pool of
data using a sampling strategy
and we expand the data set with newly
acquired labels
and then this process keeps going on
until some kind of halting criteria is
met
and some standard halting criteria is
maybe we reach a
certain uh performance threshold in the
in our
classifier train classifier or it could
also be
that we ran out of labeling budget or we
run out of unlabeled pool of data so
that's the basic pipeline of
active learning and i specifically
mentioned
uh labels in the in the step three is
because
typical active learning pipeline we
request one label
at each iteration but there is a
theoretical result in new reef 2013
which shows that even if we do
bulk active learning where we are just
requesting labels for
a batch of examples we can still uh
don't lose much performance and there
are some theoretical results on that
so now i focus on the first step
how to create a seed set so recall that
a help speech has a nuanced definition
and our goal is to obtain a seed set
containing diverse set of examples
satisfying all subclasses so
what we do is we start with an example
for each subclass
and we find nearest neighbors in the
comment embedding space
so
for example uh if it's about
organizational health
an example comment could be you and
should help the rohingyas
if it's about advocating for the rights
it could be
knowing as should get me and mr
citizenship it could be
uh value the humanity they are migrating
for lives not for luxury
when it comes down to expressing empathy
and so on
so the reason the two top two comments
are written in blue
uh font is because
these two comments are not coming from
the original
data set so we uh uh
suggested the annotators that if by
quickly
scheming through a small part of the
data set
you don't find any comment that
satisfies
any of these criteria you can write your
own
short example comment that satisfies
this particular condition and
this is particularly very useful
in the case of rare classes because in
real positives
if we don't have an example comment that
satisfies
uh this particular sub subclass criteria
the annotators can actually write their
own example and then we can perform
nearest neighbor sampling
and then start find finding comments
from the actual data set
in the case of negatives
we did not have the problem of finding
examples from the data set
so if it's called for violence then an
example comment is pakistan please nuke
mind mar buddhist
supporting the alleged oppressor well
done myanmar
and this particular criteria was very
interesting we call it what about autism
so we notice that ah
a typical tendency in online
discussion is whenever there is one
disadvantaged community
uh some uh commenters will say what
about some
other disadvantaged community as if the
suffering from
suffering of one disadvantaged community
can somehow be
explained or justified by the suffering
of some other disadvantaged community
uh i would also like to mention that uh
in the call for violence
uh here uh pakistan please nuke myanmar
buddhists
the violence is uh being
perpetrated against the alleged
oppressor
in our help speech definition
violence against the alleged oppressor
is also not allowed
so this is still an example of negative
help speech
so the advantages for our active
sampling is as i already mentioned
examples need not to come from the data
set which is particularly very useful
for their classes
and since we uh used uh sub subword
information
in our in obtaining our document
embeddings
it's very robust to spelling variations
and errors which is useful in noisy
social media setting
and uh because we are starting from each
subclass
we are coming up with an example comment
and then we are finding the nearest
neighbors
so we are or are implicitly obtaining
better subclass representations because
from each subclass
we are just expanding using nearest
neighbor sampling
now uh we focus on the step three of our
active learning pipeline is uh use the
model to request labels
uh from the unlabeled pool using a
sampling strategy
so as i already mentioned the typical
strategy
in active learning is uncertainty
sampling where the learner request
labels for which
the classifier is most unsure about
however for rare class problems
certainty sampling is a technique
where the classifier the learner request
labels for which the classifier is
most sure about so when
the minority class is the positive and
you want to jack up the number of
positives
so the minority class certainty sampling
could be an effective way
to jack up the number of positives and
this has been previously
used to improve class imbalance in other
short document domains and
this was my internship project with paul
and ryan
and in this paper
we use a combination of both uncertainty
sampling and certainty sampling
so here a quick look at our over overall
scheme
so we first start with a small set of
example comments
so in our help speech definition we have
six
classes for positives and five
subclasses for negative
so we start with six positives and five
negatives
then we perform nearest neighbor active
sampling we
end up with 38 positive and 273
negatives
then we perform a round of random
sampling to improve diversity
and as you can see that there is still a
huge gap between the number of positives
and negatives
in step 4 we perform certainty sampling
to tackle class imbalance
and we breach the gap between the
positives and the negatives and we
finally
end with a step up uncertainty sampling
and at the end of this step we end up
with a roughly
same number of positives and negatives
so our overall
data set is finally balanced
uh we trained a lexical baseline
svm with unigram diagram and trigram as
features and we see
that the f1 score steadily increases
as we keep obtaining more data
and also breaching the class imbalance
so our final f1 score is
close to 76 percent and uh
it's it's very easy to uh squeeze more
performance out of the classifier
so instead of just a svm train with n
grams as features
if we use a svm train with engrams
plus we consider the embeddings as
feature we see that
there is a performance boost that we
obtain
but our main goal is not to uh
squeeze as much performance as we can
from
the train and test split we are more
interested
in observing what happens in the wild
so uh in the wild means we ran our
classifier
on the part of the data that is that
belongs neither to the train
not to the test so it's uh data it's
completely out of
our train test split and when we run
our help speech classifier we obtain top
100 comments predicted
as help speech and when we do human
annotation
we find that 88 of them were marked as
positives by our human annotators
recall that random sampling just yielded
10.77 percent positives
so this indicates that our
classifier can substantially reduce web
moderation
we were also interested in seeing
uh if the the positives that we find in
the wild
if they represent each of the subclasses
well
and we find that uh for each of the
subclasses
for help speech we find more than
one comments satisfying that particular
subclass
so our obtained data set our obtained
comments are
diverse also now i like to pause a
little bit
and let you read this comment this is an
example positively found in the wind
so as we see that uh the word
citizenship
uh ethnic cleansing even about help
these are spelled uh incorrectly
and there are a lot of grammar
disciplinary also in this comment
so we suspect this is uh most likely
written by a rowinga user
and the fact that our classifier could
find this comment in the wild
it indicates that uh our method holds
promise in
performing uh well uh in the wild
dealing with this kind of grammar and
spelling dispenses
so uh this is another example comment
that
made us to think about something else
for example
this comment which says that the myanmar
government is really kind of like
animals our annotators mark it as
positive and we asked him why
and the explanation was assuming that
the atrocities
alleged atrocities are real some
measured expression of anger is expected
now the question is where to draw the
line
is this uh still help speech because
it's containing hate speech
about the lh officer and the more
important question is
who gets to draw it so this kind of
examples actually
made us aware of the challenges the
typical challenges
also we find in hate speech detection
because
how to give very thorough and crisp
and precise guidelines to the annotators
to describe
what is help speech and what is not is
is a very uh challenging problem and
this one comment actually made us aware
of
this challenge the takeaways from
the first part of our project is a
different we looked into a different
aspect of web vulnerability of
marginalized communities and that's the
sparsity
of pro-minority voices championing their
cause
and we looked into air's possible role
in addressing this
uh we also emphasize that hate speech
and help speech they serve two different
goals
and embedding based methods whole
promise in tackling noisy social media
data
we also found that combining active
sampling and active learning it can be
an effectively
effective strategy to address class
imbalance
now this idea of surfacing
positive content uh what could be some
of its broader applicability
so we focused on another domain where
uh we feel that just simply blocking the
hate
will not be an enough strategy
so we focused on heated online
discussions between nuclear adversaries
india and pakistan again our choice of
platform was
youtube and the research question this
time
is like when the civilians of two
uh nuclear adversaries are at the like
at the brink of war and people are
engaging in heated political discussion
can ai help in detecting peace seeking
hostility diffusing content
um a quick background of the conflict
that we looked into so we looked you
looked into a short span of like four
weeks uh
in favor starting from 14th feb 2019
and that lasted for for about a month
uh so on 14th feb there was
a terror attack that happened in kashmir
and a pakistan-based
militant organization claimed
responsibility
soon after that a lot of diplomatic
escalations
started happening and then
in on 26 feb indian government claimed
that they
performed an air strike in india in in
pakistan
and which claimed massive casualties
and on 27th feb uh
an indian pilot got captured by pakistan
and in between the 26th 27th and 20th
feb
in those three days the two countries
countries came precariously close to
declaring full-fledged war up until in
on first march the pakistan prime
minister imran khan
released the indian pilot
as a peace gesture and the
uh the immediate tension between the two
countries
were somewhat subdued after that but
still it's it's a very
uh uh tense political situation between
these two countries and if we look at
the history
their uh acrimonious past dates back
from like 15 august 1947 to till today
and uh kashmir is a disputed region
since the inception of the two countries
there have been four full-blown wars and
many skirmishes and both countries are
nuclear powers
and a recent study reported that should
there be a full-blown war between the
two
countries there could be
as many as like 100 million deaths
so again uh in this work uh we focused
on
nearly two million comments on uh videos
relevant to
this pulvama terror attack and uh
when we used our polyglot embedding
based language identifier
we could separate 1 million english
comments
so you can see from this
visualization that there are three
clusters and which means that we just
needed
to annotate 30 comments
10 per cluster to process this 2.04
million comments
and obtain monolingual separation
so again this this is very annotation
efficient
in terms of the english written by
uh non-native speakers we had very
similar challenges as our rohingya
project
this is one example common thank you
pakusta for humanity novar
so you can see a lot of spelling
disfluency
and 32 percent of the times
liar was misspelled as li er so there
are a lot of spelling errors in in the
data set
so similar to help speech we define a
new task of
detecting hope speech which is a nuanced
classifier
detecting hostility diffusing content
it could be a peace seeking
suppose for example we want peace or it
could talk about humanitarian cost of
war
peace is better than war as the price of
war is death of innocent peoples
and it could be appreciation for
neighbor i'm from pakistan i love india
and indian people
and it can go on there are many more
subclasses which i am not describing
here
so using a similar techniques as our
health speech classifier we built a hope
speech classifier and we were again
interested in looking at the performance
in the wild
so uh when we do random sampling uh
we only obtain 2.5 percent hope speech
so again this is
earlier class uh rare positive mining
task
uh our classified in the wild yields
84.7 percent uh hope speech that are
uh evaluated by human so
again we obtain substantial improvement
in web moderation
if we look at the different
subclass representation we see that in
the wild we
also find positives belonging to
different of the
different subclasses in our
hope speech definition
here some example hope speech we found
in the wild
and the particularly interesting one is
this one in peace
bury their fathers in war fathers bury
their son
this is originally by herodotus some
2500 years back and it's
uh being reproduced on youtube comments
uh tells us that in the last 2500 years
we still
as like a human humanity we still
haven't
been able to fully understand the
futility of war
we conducted a
a a study of how
the pro peace and pro-var intent
evolved over this uh four weeks of time
and for this we created a comprehensive
set of intent
phrases and we uh
we counted the number of comments
normalized by the total number of
comments posted
for that particular day to evaluate how
the peacekeeping and the war seeking
stance evolved over time and
surprisingly what we found in this
analysis
is when the threats of war became
imminent
common people actually tend to gravitate
towards peace
so this was a very interesting social
science result
that we found in this work that when the
two countries
uh became precariously close to
declaring a war
uh we can see also there is a huge spike
in the number of comments
also posted during that time so most
likely the senior voices
the voices that don't think that word is
a good solution
they uh participated uh heavily in the
discussion
expressing that what is not a good idea
so this was a very
interesting uh social science result
that we obtained in this
paper uh now i move to
uh the final part of of this talk so
for people who don't understand hindi
the top comment
would not make uh much of a sense uh
however
like i love india and i am pakistani
peace peace peace
this we understand is a peacekeeping
conciliatory comment now the fun part of
the whole thing is
this is the same comment so i love india
i am pakistani maya
peace peace peace so this phenomena is
known as
code switching which is a seamless
transition of languages
within the same document boundary so
typically
code switching is looked at as an
obstacle to downstream analysis
and there are many important work on
switch point detection token level
language detection
however in this comment we
find an interesting observation that a
short document
is likely to express a consistent
sentiment
and there could be interesting sentiment
parallelism
so although i don't understand what
ma'am chattahoochee exactly means
but since it's a part of a peacekeeping
comment
i can have an educated guess that may be
met
amancia vastu jangni also means
something peaceful
so the research question is can we
harness code switching
to perform cross lingual sampling for
social good
consider we have a document level
sampler
of code switch comments and we also have
a precise
word level language identifier so using
this
we can actually sample code switch
documents
that exhibit hope speech we first use
the sampler
to obtain a code switched comment and
then
we run the hope speech classifier
and using both we can actually find code
switch documents exhibiting hope speech
once we have this code mixed comment we
can extract the hindi part of the code
switched comment
and we can perform nearest neighbor
sampling of the extracted hindi part
in the hindi region so
let's start with a simple example and
then it will become more clear
so before i start our language
identification method
that we presented based on polyglot word
embedding
it also works well at the word level so
we can use it to sample documents with
substantial code switching
so suppose this is uh the comment that
we were looking at i love india and
pakistani
peace peace peace so when we run our
token level hindi extractor so the
extracted hindi is
so it makes a mistake it thinks vaste is
west
but nonetheless in spite of this noisy
extraction
when we perform nearest neighbor
sampling
of this noisily extracted hindi comment
we find that a comment purely written in
hindi
as any nearest neighbor which translates
to i am a rajput
i never want fight between the two
countries we were one country before the
partition
only a handful of extremists want
bloodshed
so visually
if we look at this diagram
the blue region represents comments in
english
the red represents comments in romanized
hindi that is hindi written in roman
script
the code mixed region is the black
region between
the two language clusters
and we can see that the magenta
triangles are the code mixed hope speech
but once we extract the hindi out of the
code mixed hope speech
and we perform nearest neighbor sampling
we see that the nearest neighbors
are all in the hindi uh region
outside the code mixed region right
so just using the code mixing this
phenomena as a bridge
uh we obtain a tenfold sampling uh
performance improvement so if we just
randomly sample in the hindi region
we will get around like two percent hope
speech and
with this uh sampling method we get like
23 percent and which just comes for free
just by utilizing code mixing and the
intuition
that if there is a short document
written in two different languages
chances are pretty high whatever is
the sentiment expressed in language a
will be very
similar to the sentiment expressed in
language b
now uh when we work uh with a fast
moving crisis
like uh the current kobe 19 crisis we
may not
have a content classified even in
english so if we are heavily constrained
with
uh with a situation that we don't even
have
a content classifier but we have some
example english comments
can we perform cross lingual sampling to
obtain
similar hindi comments uh using this
phenomena
so turns out that with using a clever
cheek
this can be achieved so suppose we start
with an english comment
and the comment is we should maintain
social distancing
in step 2 we try to find nearest
code mix neighbor and when we
perform the nearest neighbor sampling
with the english comment
we disable the hindi part so
we should maintain social distancing is
actually matched with obeying social
distance
is important we completely disregard the
hindi part
while we are computing the nearest
neighbor in this step
in the next step we now focus on
the hindi part
and then we try to find what are some
similar comments
in the hindi region that is similar to
this
logo and when we do uh
nearest hindi comment with english
disabled and hindi enabled
we find something like june bana bahar
mad kumafiro
so effectively this means like we are
almost performing something like a chain
database query
where the english component and the
hindi component are two
keys and which are acting as the bridge
from for us to move from the english
example comment to find something
equivalent
in the hindi region so once we did
this experiment on a kobe data set
uh we found that we with our sampling
technique
we find five times more positives
than the random baseline and these
comments express
compliance to cdc guidelines um
i would like to say one more
thing that in low resource
language setting i mean typically
linguistic resources
uh focus on economic forces like
whichever
uh language has more uh
the importance of a certain language is
often decided by economic forces
but during a pandemic the lingua
linguistic resource demand might get
recalibrated
and spaces or regions that are very
densely populated
whatever language they mainly speak we
would need
uh rapid resources for those kind of
languages
so by harnessing code switching in this
way
we can actually perform cross lingual
sampling and transfer
resources in world languages to
uh its uh low resource counterparts
uh this is actually a short digestion we
had a
discussion uh with manojit two days back
about our paper which is not exactly
related to all this work that i was
describing
but he said like i should include just
one slide to describe it
so uh there has been a recent mnlp paper
where uh bert was used as a knowledge
base
so burt has its mask
word prediction model right so what they
did
was they will say that dante was born in
musk
and then what will give us solutions
like number of certain words ranked by
probability
and it it was found that uh the top
predicted word is florence
in this case and again uh they uh asked
about a mask query
theory of relativity was proposed by
mask so bert can
correctly predict einstein so uh in this
paper
they explored the capability of bert
to be used as a knowledge base we
took a leaf out of this publication and
went one step ahead
and wanted to see that can we use
fine-tuned language models
for polling tasks like if we have a
corpus of indian election and we
fine-tune what
can we ask like vote for mask or mask
will win
then see what kind of political entities
what predict with what probability
so that could be useful for polling then
we can also
track evolving national priorities
suppose there is a must query the
biggest problem of
india is musk then what does work
predict does it predict
uh unemployment poverty or does it
predict
pakistan and kashmir depending on what
time range
we are interested in and also
we can track perception of religious
communities like hindus our mosque and
muslims are masked
and we can track what kind of words are
predicted by birth
when we ask this kind of religious
perception question
so uh the paper the main takeaways of
this paper was
asking this kind of a must query can be
an effective method to obtain coarse
grained insights
and we also find that there is some
amount of religious polarization in
india
so there is a lot of negative perception
around both religions
so uh so finally i'm at the last slide
in this work uh we talked about
a framework novelty where instead of
blocking the head
we focus on amplifying the positives uh
we found that polyglot embedding based
language identification is very useful
not in the rowing of just the rohingya
project or the india pakistan project
in the 2019 indian general election we
dealt with 12
regional indian languages and it it was
very
uh useful we found active sampling is a
is an effective technique uh both in
rohingya refugee crisis and india
pakistan conflict
and finally we found code switching can
be harnessed for social good
uh in all this work uh while we were
writing the papers
we were pleasantly
surprised by the rich
body of work done by the
melange group in msr india
and it actually made our work so much
easier because
whenever we have to say like there is a
lot of code switching
in indian languages we can just cite a
relevant paper
or a lot of the content in social media
is
romanized use romanized hindi or
romanized regional languages
we have a paper to cite so it was very
useful for
our research to establish why and how
the problems are important
finally uh this work was
done with jaime
carbonaire jaime was my phd advisor
postdoc mentor
and i have been working with him for the
last nine years
when we were working on all these
projects uh hani was uh
going through um a very serious health
struggle
uh nonetheless uh it was uh like
uh i cherish every single moment that i
got a chance to work with him and this
projects were very close to his heart
and
i would like to dedicate this work to
him thank you
thank you ashik it was a really
wonderful talk
and i'm sure there will be many
questions so people who have questions
please raise your hand and we can go in
order and maybe i can start with a quick
question
so uh all the comments uh that you
showed
except for one or two where long
and when there are long comments so
specifically the one you said
most probably a rohingya person wrote
where there are lots of spelling errors
and everything
but since it was a very long comment i
would assume that there is enough
um you know evidence of it being a help
speech
because of words like stop genocide and
things which are
written properly so i was wondering what
is the accuracy of this system i mean
do you have a feel for it for shorter
comments because that's where we find
most of uh you know the systems fail and
it becomes very hard to build something
robust
like let's say five word comments or 10
or less than 10 word comments did you
do some such study we did not do
a uh like
thorough analysis on like i don't have a
number for you
but many many of the comments were
actually on the shorter side
and there was a good mix and actually
one of the reasons
uh youtube is very an interesting medium
in this case because for twitter you
have an upper bound right
for youtube we don't have any upper
bound of
of the length of the comment so there
was a huge uh variance in in the comment
length
and i think the number is presented in
the paper so there were a lot of short
comments and there were many long
comments as well
and i think the classifier performed
reasonably well across
both that that's great to know i will
check it out uh the the other one which
i found really intriguing was this
herodotus
comment that you have which was very
hard even for me as a human to pass i
had to read it couple of times to get
okay this is what it is saying and
therefore it's a help speech
so uh have you tried you know swapping
the clauses so suppose we had
i mean i i'm sure probably you didn't
try but if we swap the clauses like
inward i put what happens in peace and
vice versa
so it just changes the polarity of the
comment inside
in that sense would it still uh would
the system
still detect it as uh you know a help
speech
uh i mean something uh i thought would
be interesting to do
um we have uh tried uh
i mean like we did not try is explicit
explicitly swapping
but we noticed that suppose someone is
saying that
word is not a solution ah peace is the
solution
and then there is someone ah another
comment what
is the only solution uh this kind of uh
uh juxtaposition of just
warden piece interchanging uh between
them
and uh since we are using engrams uh
most of the cases i think it was uh
it correctly classified but yeah there
were few cases where
it fails so i think if we want to do a
more
robust uh classifier
using some this kind of adversarial
examples
and training the classifier could be
could be an interesting detection
yeah yeah i mean i it was more like my
you know
nlp mind you know triggering up
but otherwise yeah those might be corner
cases anyway
anirudh do you have a question yeah hi
so i had a question about the part where
you mentioned about the
nearest neighbors search for finding
more examples
right one thing that wasn't clear to me
was like
uh are you performing the
nearest neighbor search to find comments
and then using that
in the active learning or how is it
because
wouldn't you get a lot of negative
examples also when you do that
yes so like we have an example comment
and then we want to find uh
we want to expand that particular
subclass right suppose
rohingya should get myanmar citizenship
and then when we
uh do nearest neighbor sampling in the
comment uh
embedding space there will be some place
cases where we will also
find uh examples like rohingyas should
not
get myanmar citizenship because
it i almost identically matches the seed
comment
uh but it completely changes it changes
the polarity
so the reason uh it uh this nearest
neighbor sampling
was uh came uh was useful because we
have a human in the loop
so the nearest neighbors uh sampling is
allowing us
to find comments that are structurally
uh or
maybe likely semantically similar to the
seed comment
but then the human in the loop is making
sure that
the comments are labeled accordingly
does that answer your question yeah
i just have one more thing so these
plots of these embeddings
they are uh three snake plots
any other question
[Music]
yeah so i i have a question
yeah yeah and so i i really like the
last comment that you made
in the the that first project that uh
i mean that was the first question that
i had that what happens if
hope speech turns into a hate speech by
looking at the other group
whether you call it majority or whatever
and
i mean perpetuating some sort of hatred
for that group itself and who is to draw
the line
the second part is whether i mean
socially or politically we don't know
but how do we train annotators
uh i mean what are the uh
whether you have made certain
observations about that
that how do you train annotators at
least to make sure that
this this doesn't happen like the whole
uh
the fact that i mean it's a fantastic
thing to think
that uh i mean you are doing hope speech
in an
era of hate speech which is uh something
that i really liked
i mean i was getting a little bit sleepy
because
i just woke up but you're kind of
i mean presentation got more motivated
me
to wake wake up completely so yeah that
was that was my question actually so
whether you have found uh certain other
things as well how to train annotators
um so uh what we did like
when we uh it's we
presented the results in very details in
in the papers
so uh we try to adjust bias
in like various levels so for example
a large part of our work focused on
obtaining
related search queries from google
trends data
and there is a result that if
there are two entities you tend to place
the entity ahead of the pair
whoever you feel closer to like for
example if
a republican posts a
search query he will say trump hillary
election
and the democrat is likely to say
hillary trump election
so similarly when we were finding a
google
trends result when we were focusing on
indian google queries we always put
india ahead of pakistan
uh when there is a search query
where we have india and pakistan in the
pair and whenever we
our geographic location was pakistan we
swapped that and made it pakistan india
conflict or something like that so even
in that level we wanted to
reduce bias when we uh worked with the
annotators
unfortunately we did not have a
pakistani
annotator so both annotators were from
india
so there uh since uh
the time period of this conflict
was extremely close to uh to
indian general election we uh removed uh
any uh comment uh during the election
while constructing the training set that
uh
contains the name of the indian prime
minister
and also for a consistency we also
removed
the name of pakistani prime minister
directly
so that the political affiliation bias
of the annotators do not affect or
influence the data
so there also we find that it's a very
challenging task
to ah to construct a data set
where uh there are like so so much
uh uh uh like it's so politically
charged right
so uh we wanted to eliminate certain
things like that
to make sure that uh biases are
addressed
but it's a very interesting direction
where
future research can go exactly
great great to know thank you thank you
okay i think we are out of time but yeah
ashik
it has it was a really really wonderful
talk again thank you
and thanks everybody for joining uh
nadeem has recorded the talk so we will
put it on resnet
and those who especially from redmond
people who wanted to join and couldn't
they can
watch the talk offline okay and thanks a
lot for
giving me this wonderful opportunity
thank you thank you
thank you bye